You shouldn't get married young,
because by the time you finish growing up,
you're gonna want different things in life.
At least that's what I've been told.
And as someone who got married 18,
I can attest
you will want different things in life after you finish growing up.
I'm only 22, and I know my brain hasn't finished developing yet,
but I can barely recognize the person that I was before I got married.
I have changed in so many ways,
and I've turned into a confident
young woman with very different life goals than I used to have.
But this change has not been bad.
It's been good.
And if anything,
it's brought me closer to my husband.
Him being my constant
best friend throughout the last four years has been so wonderful.
We're closer now than we ever have been.
We're more obsessed with each other than we were when we got married.
Change is a good thing.
You should expect. It happens no matter what age you are.
Marriage will definitely change you.
I love who I'm becoming.
I love my husband is becoming.
You shouldn't be scared of change.
When you get married and you commit yourself to that person,
you're making a promise,
and that promise must be kept.
I've never once doubted the promise that I made.
And while many,
many things have changed about me and around me,
I remain ever thankful that I said yes to marrying him
when I was Eighteen.
I know I'm only four years in,
but it's been a really wonderful four years of marriage so far.
Cheers to change.
Cheers to maturity.
Cheers to growing up together.
Marriage is not scary because you don't have to go through it alone,
and that is the fun part.